[Music]
Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and the center for security
policy an Islamic jihadist screaming
Allahu Akbar open fire in a crowded
Istanbul nightclub on New Year's Eve
2017 murdering 39 people and injuring 69
others and immediately the proforma
condemnations began pouring in serving
only to highlight the futility and
wrongheadedness of the West's response
to the global Jihad outgoing President
Barack Obama called Turkish president
Reep tayip erdogan to tell him that he
strongly condemned the massacre National
Security Council spokesman Ned price
said that the United States condemned
the horrific terrorist attack in the
strongest terms US state department
spokesman Mark toner said that the US
government strongly condemns the
terrorist attack Obama and the US
government condemned a terror attack how
reassuring was it ever really in doubt
where they would come down on this issue
these condemnations from Western leaders
are Hollow and meaningless indeed they
constitute an admission of impotence
unless they're backed up by action
outgoing defense secretary Ash Carter
appeared to be promising some kind of
action as he declared that this attack
only redoubles our resolve to stand
shoulder-to-shoulder with our Turkish
allies in condemning these attacks and
relentlessly combating terrorism but did
the Obama Administration in its final 2
weeks really have any intention of doing
anything at all to pursue the Istanbul
Jihad murderer and bring him to Justice
certainly not and it wasn't just a
matter of time running out on the
administration either this same charade
has played out after every Jihad
Massacre the condemnations and
Declarations of resolve are plentiful
but real action against Jihad Terror
much less even a realistic
acknowledgement of its motivating
ideology has been much harder to find in
this case as in all others the
condemnations will not be backed up by
any action whatsoever they don't mean a
thing except as an exercise and
bizarrely gratuitous virtue signaling
the impotence and denial was not limited
of course to the Obama Administration
NATO Secretary General Jen's stoltenberg
tweeted tragic start to
2017 but the Istanbul Massacre was not a
tragedy a tial wave is a traged try this
is a war to pretend that Jihad terror is
a tragedy is to imply that it's
inevitable it's an act of God it's part
of life just something one has to
tolerate the way victims of a
devastating hurricane simply have to get
on with their lives Jihad terror is
nothing like that at all it is
preventable it can be stopped but it can
only be stopped if authorities make the
hard choices to implement measures that
people such as Jens stoltenberg wouldn't
dare even contemplate a moratorium on
Muslim immigration the deportation of
criminal aliens the requiring of mosques
to teach against the al-Qaeda Isis
understanding of Islam and more since
the current mainstream authorities would
rather be caught dead than Implement
Politically Incorrect measures these
tragedies will continue to become more
common meanwhile the European Union's
foreign policy Chief Federica mugeri
vowed we continue to work to prevent
these tragedies but actually they don't
EU immigration policies are actually
evidence of them working to make such
attacks more common all of the jihadis
who murdered 130 people in Paris in
November 2015 had just entered Europe as
refugees is it racism is it xenophobia
to recall that in February 2015 the
Islamic State boasted that it would soon
flood Europe with as many as 500,000
refugees the Lebanese education Minister
said in September 2015 that there were
20,000 active jihadis among the refugees
and camps in his country and 80% of
migrants who have come to Europe
claiming to be fleeing the war in Syria
aren't really from Syria at all why are
they claiming to be Syrian and streaming
into Europe and now into the us as well
an Islamic State operative gave the
answer to that question when he boasted
in September 2015 shortly after the
migrant influx began that among the
flood of refugees 4,000 Islamic State
jihadis had already entered Europe he
explained their purpose he said it's our
dream that there should be a caliphate
not only in Syria but in all the world
and we will have it soon
inah these Muslims were going to Europe
in the service of that caliphate they
are going like refugees he said but they
were going intent on sewing blood and
Mayhem on European streets as he said
this to journalists he smiled and he
said just wait also on May 10th 2016
Patrick calvar the head of France's dgsi
internal intelligence agency said that
the Islamic State was using migrant
routs through the Balkans to get jihadis
to Europe now Federica moini and her
European Union colleagues they are the
people most responsible for this
situation it is her tragedy that of her
friends and her colleagues because of
their policies there will be many more
such attacks their empty condemnations
won't change a thing their vows to fight
against this do anything they only
highlight the absolute failure of the
response of mainstream authorities to
the global Jihad threat I'm Robert
Spencer had driven into a crowd of
holiday makers 86 people from 19
different countries died in the Carnage